Tommy gets offstage and they go yeah
Tommy come with us guy and they take him
around the corner and the guy is
handcuffed to a chair and they go take a
couple reps set up there you go and he
Tommy just lights this dude up
[Applause]
Podcast oh v talk radio I want to tell
you a story about Boston Massachusetts I
started doing stand-up comedy there and
it is the place to learn
stand-up because it's not in Boston you
don't perform for the crowd you perform
against the crowd there's a winner and
there's a loser and and when you're
first start coming up it's like you
realize very quickly
it's saloon comedy and it's guys from
Southie they go what do you taste Sully
fitzy what are you doing tonight kid
let's go downtown heckle some quiz
then we'll go down beat up some college
kids come on guy so they come out to
these clubs and they and the the comics
are you know these are badass dudes and
they there was a lot of drugs and there
was a club called stitches comedy club
and the comedian's used to sit at the
bar and do coke while they watched each
other they'd get paid a hundred bucks
cash they would immediately hand it to a
guy guy would give them an envelope of
coke and they'd chop it up and the club
told them they could no longer do coke
at the bar and they had a strike for
four days the comedians went on strike
and so they were allowed to snort
cocaine at the bar and they had a guy
that was one this one guy named Tommy
like the best comedian I've ever seen
this guy out of Boston I can't say his
last name for legal reasons that because
this next story involves him perhaps
committing a felony he was on stage and
some wiseass from Southie he gets it he
goes back and forth with him guy throws
a bottle at tommy cops are in the back
of the club because the cops would hang
out at stitches and so with the
prostitutes because it was in the
red-light district so the back of the
room was cops who were pretty much on
the take the mob owned the place and and
so these cops happened to be in the back
and they grabbed the guy who threw the
bottle and they take him out and I'm
just thinking they are throwing a
beating on this dude right now but then
Tommy gets offstage and they go yeah
Tommy come with us guy and they take him
around the corner and the guy is
handcuffed to a chair and they go take a
couple rip set up there you go and he
Tommy just lights this dude up shift
stomach I think oh yeah that felt pretty
good thanks now we'll go do a couple
lines off the bar and relax so the first
time I ever did stand-up comedy was that
stitches at this thing called Sunday
night's Amateur Night and they called it
comedy hell that literally would be
written on the marquee comedy hell and
it was hosted by a guy named George
MacDonald and he would start to show off
by saying
welcome to comedy hell where the dreams
of a handful of Road comics can soar as
high as the lights on Broadway or crash
and burn and that fiery pit known only
as comedy hell and I go up and I
remember my first time I followed a guy
out of Providence who was dressed as a
clam
and he's saying mannish boy I'm a man
but it was on a clam get it because he
was dressed I know if he mentioned he's
dressed as a clam
and he kills destroys the place ah and
I'm in the back oh and like holy I
have no clam outfit I'm and so I
go up HUS stage and I tank it I am
eating it and it's going so poorly on
between jokes and I overhear a woman in
the front row say to her husband it was
worse than being yelled at because she
didn't think I'd hear it and so so I
sari work this Club and I become a
regular and then I come in one Sunday
night and there's a Jewish singles night
that's in the club so they all the you
know these rich kids from Boston have
got the room for the night and so the
room is filled with these kids and then
there's one table for four up front with
only one person at it and he's heckling
everybody and it turns out that he's
this guy from the Israeli army who's a
cab driver and he heard Jewish singles
night and thought I am real Jew they
would love me it's like no they love the
Jewish guy not the Jew guy they want the
guy the pre-med Jew guy and so he's
heckling everybody but here's the thing
he's good he's like a heckling savant he
goes inside people's heads and he breaks
them down
there's a girl onstage and she and she's
bombing and he goes he goes to her
you'll have loneliness in your eyes and
another yeah another guy gets up and and
and he says this is okay you you lack
basic confidence you can't come back
from that once you're told that it only
gets worse as you try to say no I do
have confidence and so I'm watching this
and I'm like but what I've learned
from watching Boston comedy is you fight
for that space you don't give that
away so I'm ready and I go on I'm three
minutes in my act
and he goes you are a man like I'm a
superhero like I should have an F on my
chest and leap over dicks and and so and
it does make you think all right if he
was so on the money on these other guys
is that what people think about me that
I'm a man and I'm angry but I'm angry at
myself maybe I should have whatever so
so now he calls me this and so then I
just go right after him I go all right
pal
you want to get in my head how about I
get in yours I go you is the worst thing
you can say to a Jewish person you are a
bad Jew you left Israel
[Music]
and he says to me he looks at me he says
nothing more I said really nothing more
I go I want you to think about this
every time you're driving your cab down
Comm Ave and some ugly American gives
the Heil Hitler sign you pull over and
you give them a ride yeah and the flames
come out of his eyes and he just jumps
up onstage fists clenched come straight
at me and so I've got the microphone and
it's like it's like this kind of wire
mesh but I don't know if you remember
back in the 90s they were it was big
steel it was like a it was like a game
of Thrones weapon and so I just take it
crack him across the forehead and he is
bleeding all over his face and the
audience is like what the is
happening and then he comes at me but
now he's this stocky dude from the
Israeli army and he gets me he gets me
into a headlock and does some Krav Maga
turns me around and now my ass is
towards the audience and they just see
him raising pummeling me while my ass
goes in the air and then he gets me too
and then he starts spinning me like a
helicopter
my legs are flopping around the front
row tables are going down drinks are
smashed I'm screaming crowd screaming
bouncers bouncers are there out back
smoking a joint so it takes about three
minutes of beating before finally these
guys come onstage and they grabbed this
guy whose name was simcha by the way I
remember his name was simcha because I
remember telling him that was the name
of the village idiot and Woody Allen's
movie love and death so so they grabbed
simcha and they throw them out of the
club and I'm standing next to stage and
my neck is on fire and the club owner
comes over to me and he goes like this
he goes uh all right Fitzsimmons
you got five minutes left
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so the MC the show is now stopped the MC
then reintroduces me and I walk up on
stage and I get up there and the crowd
jumps on his feet my first standing
ovation of my life because cuz this is
Boston they'd rather see a fight than a
comedy show any night of the week
so they calm down and I just look around
the crowd and I go alright who's next
alright you guys look great